Tuesday,
we ended with the angry response in the
colonies to the passage of the stamp
act.
1765 I talked about,
I described Patrick Henry.
We had a first,
our famous revolution moment number one,
Patrick Henry speaking out in
the Virginia House of Burgesses,
talking about what he dramatically
called his colonies, dying liberty.
And at the very end of the lecture,
I mentioned that in May of 1765,
the Virginia House of burgesses
past some protesting resolutions,
ultimately known as the Virginia resolves,
I think I said resolutions on Tuesday,
and let's stick with resolves.
The Virginia resolves and the Virginia
resolves said there were a number of
different obviously resolves
and the Virginia Resolve.
They said that the colonists had come
to Virginia with equal rights to all
British subjects.
That the colonial charter confirmed that,
that Virginia is had the right to be
governed by their own legislature and that
the Virginia legislature
had never forfeited.
It's right to impose taxes
on the colony of Virginia.
I'll repeat that again. Um, the
Virginia resolves May, 1765,
Collin has had come to Virginia with
equal rights to all British subjects.
Colonial charters confirm that Virginians
had the right to be governed by their
own colonial legislature and the
Virginia colonial legislature had not
forfeited. It's right to impose
taxes on the colony of Virginia.
Now, how's it burgesses passes
these resolutions. But in Virginia,
they weren't even published in
the local newspaper. However,
they were published in Rhode Island.
Okay. I really don't make this up.
Like I feel like you're going gonna you're
going to accuse me of planting Rhode
Island randomly throughout this
course and I'm not. It's really,
it's there all by itself. Um,
Rhode Island. And why Rhode Island,
I can't tell you, but indeed by
happenstance, someone in Rhode Island,
it circulates the,
resolves a circulating.
People are reading them and
they're talking about them,
but it's somebody in Rhode Island who
publishes the Virginia resolves in a Rhode
Island newspaper.
However,
what this person does when he publishes
these results is not only publish the
ones that were actually passed,
but there are two additional results that
get published right alongside the ones
that were passed.
Um,
these were not passed and possibly
weren't really even discussed,
and they're more radical
than the other resolutions,
but they're put right alongside
with no differentiation.
And these two unpassed
more radical resolutions,
say quote,
His Majesty's Leach people,
inhabitants of this colony are not
bound to yield obedience to any law or
ordinance whatsoever designed to
impose any taxation upon them. Okay?
That's a much bolder statement than
what I just said was happening in those
Virginia resolves.
And then this sort of more radical
unpassed resolution number two that got
published said that anyone who asserted
that anyone except the Virginia Assembly
could directly tax Virginia was quote,
an enemy of this,
His Majesty's colony. Okay? Those
are two really strong statements.
The Virginia House of Burgesses did
not pass. Those did not resolve those,
but they get published in Rhode Island
right alongside the ones that were passed
and resolved. And so they go
circulating throughout the colonies.
Making Virginia look a lot more radical
than it was at that particular moment.
So news of this sort of
new radical version of the
Virginia resolves get spread
throughout the colonies and colonies are
then inspired to pass resolves of their
own. So it's an, it's an out of
Rhode Island moment. However,
it is Massachusetts that first
suggests United colonial action.
So in June, uh, 1765,
the Massachusetts Assembly sins,
a circular letter to all of the colonial
assemblies and a circular letter is
kind of what it sounds like.
A letter intended to circulate to
all of the colonial assemblies,
inviting them to meet in a congress in
New York in October of 1765 quote to
consider,
have a general and United dutiful,
loyal and humble representation of
their condition to his majesty and the
parliament, and to implore relief.
Okay, so it's a United response,
but it's also beautiful, loyal
and humble. So on the one hand,
the fact that there's going to be some
kind of a United colonial statement is
interesting and forceful, but on
the other hand, due to full, loyal,
humble, we're not, we're not this, we're
not near declaring independence here.
We're just kind of imploring relief,
making a statement that, excuse us,
we are your humble and obedient
subjects and we don't really like this.
Thank you very much. So it's,
it's that kind of a statement.
Nine colonies responded,
New Hampshire declined to participate.
Virginia,
North Carolina and Georgia couldn't
participate because their governors didn't
convene their assemblies to
elect delegates. So there
were no delegates elected.
But all in all,
there were 27 men who took part in
what came to be known as the Stamp Act.
Congress. Right? Easy enough to
remember the Stamp Act Congress,
which meant for much of October
in 1765 okay. The Stamp Act,
Congress,
the Stamp Act.
Congress was actually the first of what
we're going to see is a series of extra
legal organizations created outside of
the regular colonial political system to
resist and reform British policies.
Okay.
So it's it's a significant action on the
part of the colonies and ultimately the
stamp act.
Congress passed a series of declarations
and they kind of echo some of the
resolutions and declarations that had
been circulating and they're going to
sound not drastically different from
some of the logic that I've been talking
about in the last lecture or two and
I'll just mention four of the resolutions
passed by the Stamp Act Congress.
They declared that they owe their
allegiance to the crown like any British
subject.
They declared that they were entitled to
the Rights and liberties of any British
subject.
They said that British subjects in the
colonies could not be taxed without their
consent and they declared that trial
by jury was the right of every British
subject in the colony. So
you can see they're really
their statement saying, well,
you know where British subjects like
any other British subjects and were
demanding the rights and liberties
of other British subjects.
Now it's important to note the resolutions
are not saying that parliament had no
right to regulate trade in the colonies.
They're just saying that parliament
cannot directly tax the colonies without
their consent. So again, it's, it's a
direct statement. It's a strong statement,
but it's a respectful statement and
it's not boldly sort of altering,
at least in the minds of the colonists
and enormous change of policy.
They're kind of stating what they
think the state of things is.
So clearly the stamp that Congress
is a step towards colonial unity,
it's a significant step. Now actually
I want to add at this point, um,
the answer to a question that someone
asked at the end of class on Tuesday that
he's working over there. I think that was
yes, uni, it was a really good question.
I answer questions and then I
actually answered them in class. Um,
it was a really good question.
And the question was, um,
did anyone in parliament actually
oppose the stamp act? And if they did,
what was the logic?
It's actually a really good question.
And although I knew the answer was yes,
I couldn't tell you very
much detail about that. Yes.
So I went and did a little research.
Um, and it's interesting. Um,
most members of parliament
assumed that the stamp act was,
I suppose you could say constitutional
or that it was, you know,
above board proper that there was nothing
wrong with it as far as procedurally
and most members of parliament assume
that the colonists would agree it's
constitutional above board.
There's nothing wrong with it as
far as the fact that it exists.
The stamp act is perfectly proper. Some
members of parliament, and not a lot,
but some did admit that maybe parliament
was treading on dangerous ground,
but even these people didn't worry about
the stamp act on constitutional grounds.
They didn't say, wow, I wonder
if we have the right to do this.
Rather they worry that maybe the colonists
were going to be unhappy because the
stamp act may be would seem too
burdensome or they worried that maybe the
colonists would think this was some
kind of an aggressive display of
parliamentary power.
But members of parliament were
actually not worried about this.
Seeming as though it's something
that wasn't proper, wasn't allowable,
wasn't supposed to be done within the
confines of the British imperial system.
So basically what you're seeing here
is sort of a version of what I've been
saying in a variety of different
ways so far in this course,
I've been talking about
different mindsets,
developing and both sides sort of not
necessarily understanding that there are
different mindsets evolving here.
What you're seeing here is basically
members of parliament just fundamentally
not seeing that the colonists had
developed a different understanding of the
workings of the British imperial system
and those members who were worried about
the act, they were worried about it being
unpopular or maybe seeming too strong,
but they were not worried about any larger
sort of legal rationale as one member
put it.
I thought this was kind of a neat quote.
We are working in the dark and
the less we do, the better.
I know that's a great quote because it's
basically a member of parliament saying,
I'm not entirely sure,
like we don't really know what we're
doing and we don't really know how they're
gonna respond.
So we actually need to be careful with
what we're doing because we just don't
know what the response is going to be.
They're not gonna, they may not like it.
They actually,
it was only one member of parliament
who was a planter in the West indies.
One Guy who predicted,
I think the stamp act is going to produce
discord and confusion in the colonies.
Right. One guy. So probably afterwards
he was the guy saying, yeah,
told you you should have listened to me.
I told you I knew.
Okay.
So that's the answer to that question.
It's a really good question because I
had just never looked that up in any
detail before.
Okay.
So so far we've largely been talking
about speechifying paper pushing resolves
declarations,
newspaper announcements.
But in Boston we're now about to see some
physical resistance because there some
radicals decided no more words action.
And these Boston radicals is,
you're about to see,
they deployed a long held
colonial tradition of resistance.
They basically planned a mob action.
Now it's important to note that mobs
in early America weren't sort of wild,
violent, out of control. You know,
all kind of actions in a way that we're
sort of part of the political system.
Something that people were supposed
to do when they felt outraged. I mean,
it was sort of a way of
venting popular protest,
and usually early American
mobs were pretty conservative.
They were usually focused on protecting
the good of the community from things
like unfairly high food prices
are illegal business practices.
Normally they weren't really
excited about tearing things down.
Normally they involve some
marching and some yelling.
There was a lot of effigy burning
and then people went home.
So early American mobs again,
are almost kind of procedural.
This sort of what happens when you're
upset and you're a member of the public
and it's not only sort of average members
of the public is not only the masses
taking part in these kinds of protests.
All levels of society might take
part at one time or another.
So in the summer of 1765 some
Bostonian's decided they're going to take
advantage of this tradition,
a group of Boston radicals who eventually
call themselves the sons of liberty.
So here's yet another.
Now we're starting to get to the part of
the course where these things come out
of my mouth. And you're like,
Ding, Ding, Ding, Ding, ding,
revolutionary war moment sounds of
liberty. We had the master camera,
we're gonna have another one by
the end of the lecture today,
but here's one sons of liberty,
Boston.
So these radicals decide they're going
to take action and the sons of liberty,
basically our artisans and shopkeepers
who want to act in resistance to the
stamp act. Samuel Adams, who's
really more a member of the elite,
but he nevertheless was kind of a champion
of the artist class and he's among
their number two.
So let's look for a moment what the
sons of liberty decide to do and how it
works out.
Okay,
so basically in Boston at the time
there were two really large fraternal
organizations of artisans.
There was one in the north end of Boston,
there was one in the south end of Boston.
And the sons of liberty think, well,
you know, you have these sort of
organized groups like clubs of artisans.
Why don't we enlist the aid of one of
them? They're sort of already organized.
They already have a leader.
Maybe we could get them to help us.
It's some sort of organized
protest against the Stamp Act.
So they appealed to the south end group
who agrees to take part in some kind of
a protest.
So now we have this radical group,
the sons of liberty who have named
themselves and they're organized enough to
have names.
We have an organized force of men and we
have a focus desire to protest against
an act of parliament.
So this is on its way to being a different
kind of early American mob action
than these other ones might
have been. Okay. So in Boston,
the poor guy who is the stamp agent,
the stamp distributor
is named Andrew Oliver.
This is the person that you do not want
to be at this particular moment. Okay.
So Andrew Oliver is the one who's going
to be giving out or selling the stamps.
So obviously this group of men, they want
to do a mob action. They decide, okay,
Oliver is the target. So first they
go to his dock, side warehouse.
They assume actually that that's where
the stamped paper is going to be.
So they just destroy the warehouse.
I mean like destroy it.
Then they go to Oliver's house and throw
rocks and basically break all of the
windows.
Then they take an effigy of
Oliver and they stamp on it. Okay.
That's not my point. And that's actually
their foot, right? The stab back.
We're still paying all of her hug lackey,
early Americans with their wild sense
of humor. Um, bad puns of early America.
That's the first of these courts.
So they stamp on Andrew Oliver.
Oliver responds logically enough
by resigning as stamp distributor,
which I think was a wise move. Okay.
You think that, thank you very much.
I'm going home to my broken window
house now. No more stands for me. Okay.
Not long after that.
Maybe within two weeks,
that same group of men turn on
Lieutenant Governor Thomas Hutchinson,
who seemed like a friend to the stamp act.
This time the mob goes to his
house and they destroy it,
and I don't just mean rocks at windows,
they go to Hutchinson's house,
they smashed the windows, they break in
the doors, they smashed the furniture,
they cut the paintings,
they trashed the clothing.
They cut down the trees in his garden
and they were in the process of removing
the roof when daylight stopped them. Okay,
so this is on the one hand, it's sort
of a weird mob. They're like, you know,
excuse me, can you pass me that hammer?
I've got to remove the shingle. You know,
they're really like they're
industrious mob action,
but they're literally
completely tearing apart.
Hutchinson's pretty sort of
spiffy mansion in protest.
Um, attacks on stamp distributors
and other colonies followed.
And there were a lots of resignations
of staff agents. I'm not doing the job.
Thanks. I love my house. I
don't want to do this anymore.
So the result of all of this
kind of action is that by
November of 1765 when the
stamp act is actually going to
go into effect. So first of all,
the act actually hasn't
gone into effect yet.
Everything I've talked about is leading
up to it actually going into effect.
So November, 1765, it's
due to go into effect,
but people aren't quite sure what to do.
Do we ignore it?
Are there actually any stamp agents left?
Maybe you don't have to ignore it
because nobody will sell stamped paper.
I don't know. And some people did
just choose to ignore the act.
Others went further and decided to
boycott British goods, which has,
we're going to see further into this
course with sometimes a really effective
way to protest against the mother.
Country basically hit economically
and that's bound debt make an impact.
But in the middle of all this,
Grandville ministry fell not
because of the stamp act,
but because of insider politics.
The colonists saw this as
providential Greenville's gone.
Clearly it's assigned from providence
that we are meant to succeed here to come
out of this looking better than things
were when we were in the middle of it.
The new prime minister is
the Earl of Rockingham.
Now the Earl of Rockingham had strong
connections with London merchants.
London merchants clearly are people
who are going to be deeply effected by
colonial boycotting,
so they want the stamp act repealed.
So we've got this new prime minister,
the Earl of Rockingham.
He's in with the merchants who
are being hurt by the boy cut.
The idea now is it would be a fine thing
if we could figure out a way to repeal
the stamp act,
but the problem of course is figuring
out how to repeal it without seeming weak
while holding your
ground and rocking them.
Eventually did repeal the stamp act
in March of 1766 but to save face,
he assigned blame to the
wounded British economy.
He did not say anything about
colonial rights. He said, well,
the economy's suffering and so
we will repeal the stamp act.
He also passed at the same
time the declaratory act,
the declaratory act,
which declared in short that parliament
could pass laws for the colonies quote
in all cases whatsoever,
gave the declaratory act of 1766 really
strong statement. It's like, yeah,
we're going to repeal the stamp act,
but we're going to pass this
other act that says, you know, no,
we could basically pass laws for you
however we want to pass them so we're not
caving.
We're just sort of giving it on this
one little point now to Britain.
The Declaratory Act asserted
their control over the colonies.
They're legal control over the colonies
in all cases to the colonists because it
mentioned legislation but not taxes.
It seemed to suggest that maybe they had
made their point that parliament is not
going to assert taxation.
So in a way,
the declaratory act makes things worse.
It worsens ongoing misunderstandings
between parliament and the colonies.
The British not fully understanding the
colonial mindset about the workings of
the empire,
the colonists not viewing their own
logic as exceptional in any way.
They assume that their
logic has been understood.
The declaratory act also didn't really
encourage compromise because if you think
about it, moderates on all sides
were discredited. In England,
the Declaratory Act asserted
parliamentary power.
So it's a strong statement
of power in the colonies.
Radicals rule the day because it seemed
as though they'd made their point.
So as far as the colonies were concerned,
the stamp act crisis move many
to accept radical leadership,
it appears to be working.
It also revealed to the colonies the
power of uniting the colonies to bring
pressure against England, which
also seemed to have worked. Now,
once again in the middle of all this,
the prime minister yet again is replaced.
Clearly this is not the time to
be a prime minister in England.
It's kind of a rocky
time going on. So, um,
rocky time was not meant to be upon the
early of Rockingham goes down in this
rocky time. Um, and Charles. Yeah. And I
heard a Groan. I didn't do it on purpose.
It just sort of happened.
I'm sorry.
It's a bad plan that I take
full responsibility for it. Um,
but they are only rocking him.
His ministry falls.
Charles Townsend takes his place.
Charles Townson the new prime minister
and he's given the task of balancing the
budget in 1767 and like
Granville before him.
Townson first looks to England itself
and issues new taxes in England.
But again,
he still needs more income and he does
next turn to the colonies and he devises
a scheme that he thinks isn't going to
be too upsetting to these sort of touchy
colonials. He says he's going to proceed
quote with great delicacy, right?
Cause it's clear now they get
upset over there. I get upset.
We need to be careful.
I'm going to proceed with great delicacy.
He understands their sensitivity
by this whole issue of taxation.
So he decides he's going to ask for
customs duties on items that the colonies
import from Britain like glass,
silk,
paper, paint, and t. You can see,
you can see where we're going.
Um, but this is not an internal
tax. This is an external tax.
It's not a tax on things
within the colonies.
It's not a tax on legal documents is
not a tax on PA playing cards like the
Stamp Act.
It's an external tax.
It's customs duties and light before
Townson wants the money raised by this to
go to pay for royal administration in
the colony. So also the money raised,
isn't it? Going back to England, it's
going to be spent on the colonies.
Townson also reorganized the
custom service in the colonies,
basically tossing out old customs
agents who had been bought by colonial
merchants and putting
handpicked men in their place.
So all in all towns and thought surely
these are tame enough measures that the
colonists aren't going to object to
them at the scenes as though they're
accommodating. They're mild, nothing
very dramatic being done here.
These come to be known as the towns
and acts of 1767 and sure enough,
the initial response to the
Townson x is relatively weak,
but colonial anger is raised yet again
by a publication by a colonist named John
Dickinson.
He's a Pennsylvania and
he's in Pennsylvania and he
writes a series of letters.
First they appear in a Pennsylvania
newspaper there eventually published in
other colonial newspapers.
And then finally they're put
together and published in a pamphlet.
This is all in 1767 and the pamphlet
is named letters from a farmer in
Pennsylvania to the inhabitants
of the British colonies.
They have very literal titles and these
days is one of them, John Dickinson,
Pennsylvanian letters from a farmer in
Pennsylvania to the inhabitants of the
British colonies. Now Degas, and
actually when you read these,
he's pretty moderate in tone and most of
what he does is he uses past precedent
to argue against the right of
parliament to directly tax the colonies.
He asserts directly,
we're not talking about independence,
we're just talking about past
precedent. However, he also says,
and this is a quote from him,
we cannot be happy without being free.
We cannot be free without
being secure in our property.
We cannot be secure in our
property if without our consent,
others may as by right,
take it away.
The tax is imposed on us by parliament. Do
this, take it away. That's really clear.
Direct logic, right? We can't
be happy without being free.
We can't be free without
being secure in our property.
We can't be secure in our
property without our consent.
Others may take it away and
parliament seems to be taking it away.
So Dickinson isn't arguing
anything amazingly new here,
but he's certainly stating it
with real clarity and real power.
And he also appears to be
saying, well, you know,
some of that stuff we learned
from that whole stamp act thing.
I think they apply as well to
this new towns and to act thing.
He appears to be drawing a pattern.
So letters from a farmer in
Pennsylvania ultimately has an impact.
It's a strong statement up in Boston.
There was also some writing
going on and there Samuel Adams,
who was in the Massachusetts Assembly
wrote a circular letter that he sent to
other colonies,
yet again another circular letter.
And this time it's a circular letter
protesting against the Townson Act.
And it's moderate,
but it's criticizing the ax.
It does deny.
It's where this isn't about independence.
We're not trying to rebel here,
but it does urge joint colonial
resistance to the towns and acts.
Now, back in England, many people urged
a lenient response to this. I mean it's,
it's, if you think about it potentially,
it's a scary thing. You have this guy,
this radical guy in Boston whose urging
joint colonial resistance to an act of
parliament. So, um, as you will see,
some people get rather upset by this,
but not everybody. Some people say,
well, okay, let's not overreach, respond.
Let's not overreact. However,
the British Secretary of state,
Lord Hillsborough really saw this as
organized resistance and refuse to stand
for it.
So in 1768 privately
consulting with the Kings,
so kind of doing this off on the side,
he instructed the governor
of Massachusetts to
dissolve the Massachusetts
Assembly unless they took back the letter.
He also sent a letter to all royal
governors telling them to ignore the
Massachusetts letter or else he would
dissolve their legislatures to. Okay,
that's it. There's a strong statement
for you that's clearly bound to make.
Collin is get very,
very upset.
Hillsborough also knowing that
people are going to get upset,
urged General Thomas Gauge who's commander
in chief of the army and at the time
was posted in New York,
he urges gauge in New York to prepare
his troops in case they're needed in
Boston. Okay, so he's anticipating
there might be a response.
It would be nice to have troops
potentially ready to go to Boston.
So now troops are being organized.
There's threats about dissolving
assemblies and communication between the
colonies in the form of a circular
letter is being discouraged.
So clearly if you're a colonist at this
point there appears to be a plan of
repression, right? It plan, there
seems to be a system of tyranny.
There seems to be some kind of
organized attack on colonial liberties.
And I'm emphasizing plan and system and
organized because next week that's the
direction we're going to
be going with the lectures.
We're going to be looking at what I call
the logic of resistance or how does all
of this add up in the minds
of the colonists? What's
what, what are they drawing,
what conclusions are they drawing
based on actions that are happening.
And as we'll see in the lectures and
in the readings for next week, um,
there's a lot of conclusions being
drawn about an actual system of tyranny,
which is a very 18th century
way of kind of looking at it.
So colonists are wondering if there is
a sort of system of repression being put
in place.
Meanwhile,
parliament eventually in 1770 repeals
most of the towns of debts but does
preserve the tax on tea,
partly for revenue.
And partly to prove that they still have
the right to tax the colonies. So we're,
we're half seeing revenue raising
and half seeing an argument here,
and probably there was an assumption on
the part of parliament that by repealing
most of the acts, things would
quiet down. But as events in Boston,
we're about to prove this
would not be the case.
As we're about to see between 1768 and
1774 Boston really ends up taking center
stage and thanks in part to the
actions of Samuel Adams who really is,
you'll see today a brilliant propagandist
and a man with a really fierce sense
of his rights, his British rights and
his grievances as an English subject.
And I will add that Samuel Adams
did brew beer. He actually is.
Samuel Adams is associated with beer.
So truth in advertising who?
I have no idea.
That's an accurate portrait of Sam Adams.
Sam Adams is too ugly. Oh, poor Sam Adams.
I feel very bad now.
Oh well he's not attractive,
but I don't know what he's ugly.
I feel I feel bad and I'm going to
have to find a way to redeem Sam Adams.
Thank you very much.
No wonder I didn't think it was entirely
an accurate portrait of Samuel. Okay.
And yet he is associated with
beer. Okay. Um, so Sam Adams,
he's going to have a moment October of
1768 troops actually arrive in Boston at
the instigation of Massachusetts
Royal Governor Francis Bernard,
who's alarmed at this sort of
radical rumblings that he's hearing
parliament makes things
worse by in December of 1768
by proposing that the ring
leaders behind that circular letter
that seems like organized resistance,
that they should be brought to trial
for treason and using an obscure law.
They say that they should be brought
to trial for treason in England.
They should go to trial
in England. Okay. Again,
not something that's going to make call
and it's really happy. Not surprisingly,
when you have the next election for
the assembly in Massachusetts in 1769,
a large number of radicals get voted in
and this new assembly passes logically
enough radical resolutions. Again,
largely the work of Samuel Adams.
The, sadly not good
looking. Samuel Adams, um,
who declared in these resolutions that
no man can be justly taxed by or bound
and conscience to obey any law which he
has not given his consent in person or
by his representative. Okay. That's a,
that's a stronger statement
than the ones we've had before.
What he's saying here,
formerly like other colonial assemblies,
the Massachusetts Assembly with saying,
well, parliament can legislate for us,
but they can't directly
attacks us without our consent.
But this statement says parliament can't
legislate for us if we have no say in
the process. Bang. That's
a very strong statement.
So clearly there's a lot of,
um,
emotions that has been raised about what
the British administration is doing.
It's being vented in
radical resolves like that.
The arrival of troops in Boston in 1768
ended up really focusing these feelings
of grievance, these, this
anger, they sort of passions.
You have troops being sent to Boston at
a moment where people are angry at the
British,
surely enough,
you can see that the columns are going
to vent their feelings towards the
soldiers troops being sent to Boston.
Increase colonial assumptions that
they are being treated as second class
citizens,
as lower class subjects as people who
are not equal to other British subjects
within the empire.
And Samuel Adams said this really clearly
in a newspaper article written at the
time he wrote,
it is well known from the first landing
of the troops that the truth behavior
was to a great degree,
insolent and such as looked as if they
really believed that we were a country of
rebels and that they were sent
here to subdue us. Right? Again.
Now Adam's is propagandizing so he's
always saying things with a sort of extra
twist. But what he's saying is it was
very clear that when the troops arrived,
they were treating us like lowly rebels
and that they were sent here to subdue
us. Okay. So given all of these feelings,
fears about a tyrannical standing army
vets and saw that sort of system of
tyranny,
it makes sense that when these troops
arrive in Boston relations are not going
to be good between people in
Boston and soldiers in Boston,
which brings us to get another sort of
bell ringing revolutionary war moment.
Um,
a particularly note worthy active
resistance in Boston later memorialized by
clever colonial propagandists
as the Boston massacre, right?
That's how we know it today. They gave
it, Collins gave it that name. It's, it's,
it's a snappy name, right? We kept
that name. We liked that name.
It really has some zing.
Makes a political point.
So let's look for a minute here at
the details of the Boston massacre,
partly because they're really interesting.
As you'll see,
it's just a really interesting incident.
But also because I think if you look at
how the colonists and the soldiers are
interacting,
it really will reveal something about
the dynamic of colonial British relations
at the time.
Now first off,
it's important to understand that the
Boston massacre wasn't this little
isolated moment of conflict
between soldiers and citizens
between 1768 and early
17, 70 tensions were building
between the colonists and the troops.
And in early 1770,
there actually were a number,
several different outbursts of hostility
between townspeople and soldiers in
Boston.
So an example on March 2nd Samuel Gray,
a rope maker asked to passing
soldier if he wanted a job.
And when the soldier who was
probably underpaid said, yeah,
actually I could use as a second
job. Gray laughed and said, good,
go clean my outhouse.
This did not make the soldier happy.
So the soldiers slugged grey and
grey hit back and other people,
soldiers ran out and other Collin,
it's ran over and there was a fight.
There was a street fight.
A few days later,
March 5th another fight broke out when
another civilian said something insulting
to another soldier and they began
punching each other and there was another
street fight and that would be the first
in a series of increasingly agitated
clashes on that day. March 5th,
1770 that's going to end in gunfire.
But obviously the, the Boston massacre
is not the first moment of conflict.
Now later that evening, there's a
series of little outbursts. That day,
March 5th later that evening,
a small boy walking out on the street
began taunting a soldier and the soldier
responded by knocking him
down. Well, the boy got up,
went off,
found some other colonists in the street
and complained that a soldier over
their head knocked him down.
Okay,
so in this environment that's going to
really get a lot of colon, it's upset.
So a little ring of people surrounds
the kid like he's knocking down a kid,
we need to go get the soldiers,
right.
So a small group of colonists heads off
to the barracks to actually a cost the
soldiers,
but they're held off by guards.
Soon thereafter someone begins ringing
the bell of the Boston Meeting House.
And normally when you ring the
bell of the Boston Meeting House,
that's a signal for fire and is a
serious thing in a place full of wooden
buildings, right? So if the bell
is ringing, that means, oh my God,
there's a fire and everyone does what
they should do. When there's an alarm,
a fire, right? The, the bell goes off
and doesn't, it doesn't. It doesn't.
Some people run into the street
thinking that there's a fire.
Now from this point we have several
accounts are a number of cans about what
happened.
Some of them conflict.
And we're going to be looking
at two accounts today.
We're going to be looking at one
by British General Thomas Gauge.
I mentioned before, the commander in
chief of the British army in America,
he's posted in New York,
but he had gotten a very detailed report
about what happened in Boston from his
soldiers, his officers and men on
exactly what they think they experienced,
and then the other account is by
Samuel Adams. Radical propagandists.
Clearly it's going to be a very
different point of view. Okay,
so gage sends a very detailed report to
a member of the king's cabinet in London
based on what the British
soldiers in Boston told him,
assuming that the colonists in general
were insolent and we're pushing to get
more than they deserved.
Gage says in his statement,
he suspects that the entire
thing was deliberate.
He thinks that there is some colonists
who probably prearranged what happened.
Arm themselves with sticks, rocks, bricks
and snowballs. I'm sorry if it snowballs.
Just never sounds like a scary weapon to
me. Even though bad things happen here,
and I know I would not like to be hit with
a snowball, but it's not like a brick.
But that snowballs or
everyone's complaining about
snowballs and these accounts,
you'll see somehow it just makes it
seem less serious. I don't know why,
but anyway, he thinks it's deliberate.
He thinks the colon is prearranged.
Did that they arm themselves with sticks,
rocks,
bricks and snowballs planned the ringing
of the bell so that Bostonian's would
rise up at the signal and
attack the soldiers. Okay,
so this is what gauge assumes,
and here's gauges account.
Many people came out of their houses
supposing a fire in the town and several
officers on the same supposition
we're repairing to their posts,
but meeting with mobs were reviled,
attacked,
and those who could not escape knocked
down and treated with great in humanity.
Right? Those crude, nasty colonists
are treating the soldiers very badly.
Different mobs paraded
through the streets,
passing the several barracks and
provoking the soldiers to come out.
One body went to the main guard where
every provocation was given without effect
for the guard remained quiet from thence.
The mob proceeded to a sentinel,
a single sentinel posted upon the custom
house at a small distance from the
guard and attacked him.
He defended himself as well as he
could calling out for help. Okay.
There's like one guy according to
this account and like the mob attacks,
the one guy standing in front of the
Customs House and people ran to the guard
to give information of his danger.
So according to gauge,
people see this one guy getting
attacked by a bunch of people in.
They actually colonists run to get
other soldiers to help the one guy.
So according to gauge his account,
they're not all crazy radicals in Boston.
Some of them are out there helping us.
Captain Preston hearing the sentinel
was in danger of being murdered already.
We got to murder really fast.
He detached a sergeant and
12 men to relieve him and
soon after followed himself
to prevent any rash act on the
part of the troops. This party,
as well as the sentinel was immediately
attacked. Some colonists throwing bricks,
stones, pieces of ice and snowballs.
Once again, the snowballs at them,
whilst others advanced up to their band
nets and endeavored to close with them
to use their bludgeons and clubs calling
out to them to fire if they dared and
provoking them in the most
appropriate language. Right? Again,
rude colonists behaving badly,
so we have a group of soldiers,
they're lined up in front of the customs
house running to protect a fellow
soldier supposedly being murdered at
the hands of a crude and angry mob armed
with sticks and rocks and snowballs.
Okay,
let's segue over to Adams.
Adams writes a series of newspaper essays
for the Boston Gazette describing the
same incident,
often quoting testimony from the trial
of the soldiers that obviously it takes
place after this incident,
but also obviously quoting
them and telling the story
with his own radical flare.
Now remember here the different
reasons for these accounts,
and this is actually a great example
of the importance of thinking about the
nature of historical evidence,
who things are written to and why they're
written has a lot to do with how you
interpret them,
right?
You have these two documents being written
for really specific reasons to a very
specific audience.
So gauge is trying to explain to royal
authorities a shooting that never should
have happened.
He has to somehow justify this.
So he's appealing to the people he
sent the letter to whoever this world
authority was and he has to assume that
other world authorities are going to see
it. He's appealing to them
as fellow sophisticated
Englishman who understand the
nature of things out in this
sort of frontier, colony area,
crude colonists,
upset colonists.
So in a sense gauge is offering sort
of an extreme version of some typical
English sentiment among
about the colonies.
Adams is riding to the colonial public
and he's trying to raise a public outcry
against the soldiers and obviously
by association against the British
administration.
And clearly Adams is going to want it
to pick these soldiers as cruel and
tyrannical as all standing armies are.
So when it sentence Adams,
it's certainly going to be offering
an extreme version of some colonial
sentiment at the time
about the soldiers and,
and maybe about the British
administration generally. Okay,
so here is Adam's version. From the
moment when the bell starts to ring,
the ringing of the bells alarm,
the town it being supposed by the
people in general, there was a fire.
As the people came into the street,
the boy who had been knocked down told
them that the century had knocked him
down. Okay. And I'm actually quoting,
so this you can't blame me for this.
The boy says century knocked me down,
points at the soldier and says,
there is the son of a bitch that
knocked me down. I love that.
That detail is in the newspaper.
And that's another one of those things
that like they said that in 1770 they did.
Um, other people heard
this and cried, kill him.
The century ran to the custom house,
steps knocked at the door but
could not get in. Excuse me,
they're going to kill me.
He primed and loaded his gun and leveled
it and told the people to stand off and
call to the main guard.
Various where the dispositions and
inclinations of the people at this point,
the cooler sort advise to go home.
The curious,
we're willing to stay and see the event
and those whose feelings were warmer,
perhaps partook of the boys resentment.
And here he's trying to justify like,
okay,
there was some crazy radical guys,
but they were probably upset with the
boy, right? They weren't really angry.
They were just, of course they'd
be upset. The boy was attacked.
The soldiers moved to help the
century standing alone before the mob,
Adam said the soldiers moved
quote with a hottie air.
They push their band nets and dammed
the people as they went along.
And when they arrived at their post,
one witness who is a young gentlemen
of a liberal education and an unspotted
character
declared that one of the soldiers whom
he particularly named loaded his gun,
pushed him with his band and
damned him. Ooh, okay. So here,
according to Adams,
there's this route imperious British
soldier treating the young gentleman of a
liberal education and unspotted
character, like a lesser being. Okay,
so now both narrators have
gotten us to the same point.
We have soldiers lined up,
they've just very visibly loaded their
guns in front of them stands British.
Captain Preston with WHO's in command
of the men and in front of Preston is an
angry crowd.
So according to gauge at this point,
Preston soldiers behind him,
crowd in front of him, he's,
he's trying to calm the situation
down and supposedly he's asked,
are you going to ask those soldiers to
fire on us and presences? Yeah. See,
the guns are behind me and
you're in front of me. No, really
wouldn't be a good idea for them to fire
now because I'll die, right? He's like,
no, it's a good point, I think.
But all he could say had no effect.
And one of the soldiers
receiving a violent blow
instantly fired captain Preston
turned round to see who fired
and received a blow upon his arm,
which was aimed at his head.
And the mob at first seeing no execution
done and imagining the soldiers had
only fired powder to frighten them,
grew more bold and attacked
with greater violence,
continually striking at the soldiers.
He didn't get their guns and pelting
them and calling out to them to fire.
And we have captain Preston,
his description of what
he heard from the crowd.
He says the crowd was yelling, come
on you rascals. Bloody backs, lobster,
scoundrels, great little string
of insults. Fire. If you dare,
you dare not fire. Okay, so gauge goes on.
The soldiers at length perceiving their
lives in danger and hearing the word
fire all around them. Three or four of
them fired one after another. And again,
three more in the hurry and confusion.
Four or five persons were unfortunately
killed, unfortunately and more wounded.
Okay, so that's basically the end of
gauges account. Clearly in his account,
the soldiers are under serious attack.
Adam's tells a different story. Adam says,
yes,
the crowd was yelling at the troops,
but they had insulted the crowd and
loaded their guns. Yes, they had sticks,
but everybody was carrying sticks these
days because everyone was scared of the
soldiers. So everyone naturally walked
around in the streets with sticks. Now.
Maybe that's true. Which tells you
a lot about the streets of Boston,
or maybe it's not, in which
case it's really creative.
Yes, the crowd, he hit it,
the soldiers guns,
but they were trying to push them away.
So Adam said it's not an uncontrolled mob.
It's actually a group of people
carrying their normal everyday sticks
pushing in to here.
Captain Preston answered the question
about whether or not he was going to order
the troops to fire at this moment.
Adam says,
one of the soldiers was hit by a stick,
staggered fired his gun at the crowd upon
which several soldiers fired and says
Adams, they reloaded their guns.
They were gonna fire again.
Some of the crowd moved away.
One man went up to a soldier and asked
him to his face if he was going to fire.
And supposedly the soldier
said yes by the eternal God,
at which point the
colonist knocked him down.
I love all the detail at this point,
press and called out to his men not to
fire and they stopped. And here Adam says,
I am no soldier and never desired to
be one. But I appeal to those who are,
whether the words don't fire our
words of command and the British army,
one of,
there's not some other word which soldiers
are taught to understand more proper
to be given on such an occasion,
which would have prevented such Rashma.
So here he's saying the guy didn't
even call out like cease fire. He said,
don't stop. Great. Thank
you Captain Preston.
And then Adam's describes
the people who died.
He makes special note
of the fact that gray,
the rope maker who insulted the century
by asking him to clean the outhouse is
killed in the clash.
Coincidence or murder
Adams is good,
right?
And so here Adams is tossing out the
suggestion that maybe the troops were just
looking for an excuse to fire on the
townspeople and I'm really get that nasty
gray plotting maybe. And the
British too, as you've heard,
are wondering if maybe this is a
plot on the part of the colonists.
Maybe they're actually just
trying to rob the customs house.
And this whole thing was an elaborate
ploy by the colonist just to rob the
customs house behind the guard.
So you can really see from these two
accounts and from the details contained
within them,
the animosity and the sense of alienation
between the colonists and the soldiers
on both sides. And you can also see really
dramatically the fears on both sides,
that there's some kind of a plot.
There's some kind of a plot of resistance
or tyranny depending on which side
you're on. Somehow this is organized and
it's not good, and it has to be stopped.
And both sides have
come to that same point.
And I will stop there and we will
continue next week onto the logic of
resistance.